each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
okay so I'm pleased to introduce
Catherine Stanga who's here to speak to
us about elliptic nets with applications
to cryptography all right thank you very
much for inviting me to speak very
pleased to be here um I hope you'll
forgive me for doing this sittings that
I don't have to balance someone like the
whole time and all right so um I'm going
to be talking about the work I did in my
thesis in which i introduced the concept
of elliptic nuts but the story really
starts with elliptic divisibility
sequences which are recurrent sequences
associated to elliptic curves so I'll
start the talk off with the definitions
and properties of those and then I'll
give a definition of elliptic nets as a
generalization of the sequences and I'll
try and generate i'll try to explain
generalizations and extensions of the
properties from the sequences case
elliptic nets are a sort of alternate
computational model for the much of the
arithmetic of elliptic curves so in
order to demonstrate what they could be
used for I'm going to give a
cryptographic applications so for all
the cryptographers in the audience for
looking hopefully the second half of
that we will get there and i'll be
giving an algorithm for computing the
tape pairing now pairings in
cryptography our topic of much interest
lately and the basis of a number of
protocols but one needs to be able to
impugn the pairings and at the moment
the algorithm used is an algorithm by
victor miller so i'm going to be giving
a completely different algorithm which
is of the same complexity and i'll talk
more about the comparison as we get
towards the end learn the technology
here hey all right um so elliptic
divisibility sequences this is sort of a
heuristic this is how they how you would
catch them in the wild if you take an
elliptic if you take sorry an elliptic
curve and you take a rational point on
the elliptic curve then choosing a usual
Weierstrass equation you can write the
rational point in that form and you can
pull out a denominator which will be an
integer
so taking the multiples of a particular
point and looking at that sequence you
get an Associated sequence of integers
which are the denominators and that's an
elliptic divisibility sequence sort of
at essence but of course this isn't
actually a very good definition for
several reasons there's some issues with
cancellation of primes and things like
that but one may be obvious reason why
it's not really ideal is that this isn't
even defined um it's only to find up to
sign really so I'll give an example so
there's an elliptic curve and a point I
just ask the computer to compute the
multiples and pulled out the
denominators there and you'll notice
I've chosen the signs according to my
own devices which I'll explain later so
technology item number two all right so
to notice here is that the the third
term divides the sixth term and the
fourth term divides the eighth term
that's the divisibility of divisibility
sequences if n divides n then the nth
term will divide the amp term so here's
a better set of definitions for these so
let's start with this one this is for
for those of you who may recognize it
this is really just the aunt division
polynomial this size of n it's given in
terms of the weierstrass Sigma functions
but it has zeros just the end torsion
points so if you fix a curve and you fix
a point then to get the Associated
sequence you just take this sequence of
elliptic functions and and evaluate at
that given rational point and it's not
at all obvious looking at this
definition that these are even integers
but we'll see later that they are okay
an alternative definition um so you can
also generate the exact same sequence
that we just saw by taking some initial
values satisfying certain initial
conditions and then just generating the
sequence using recurrence relation so a
couple things to notice from from this
side it's not a first of all has nothing
to do with looked at curves on this side
and a couple things one is
in order to calculate a given term of
the recurrence you would have to divide
if you want to calculate WM + and you
would have to divide by WM minus n and
also this recurrence I mean there's
there's two variables in there and an
end so there's actually a lot of
instances of it so if you want to
calculate a particular term in the
sequence you could conceivably do so in
several different ways you could take
different paths to get there choosing
different instances of the recurrence so
it's not even quit there exists such
things because given the initial
conditions may be there is no set of
integers which satisfies that recurrence
for all possible instances but in fact
the what Morgan Ward showed when he
introduced these in 1948 is that these
definitions are equivalent and in fact
you can go back and forth very
explicitly if you have given curve and a
point then you can figure out what the
sequence is just by taking the values so
it's clear how to go from A to B but in
fact you can also go backwards with
explicit polynomial equations telling
you what for instance the the wire
stress equation the coefficients the
Weierstrass equation would be for your
curve and what the coordinates of your
point would be and in fact it's you can
it's a by jection so every sequence
which satisfies the right hand side here
does come from some elliptic curve in
point
okay so since their associated to
elliptic curves they're going to satisfy
certain certain properties reflecting
that so the most obvious one here is
that if you have an end torsion point
remember these are just dance division
polynomials for or at least they're the
another way of saying that is that the
zeros are the end torsion points for the
nth term so the ants term will vanish if
p is an end torsion point but more
exciting than that is that this happens
mod p as well if you reduce the curve
mod p and you reduce the sequence mod p
then the same thing is true if P divides
some term the sequence so it reduces to
zero that means that your point reduced
to something which had order in and
that's just another way of stating the
divisibility condition which is that the
primes appear at even intervals as you
walk along said I should point out these
sequences are defined to infinity in
both the negative and positive direction
well so live indexed by the complete
integer said okay and finally another
note thinking just heuristic alee even
given certain initial conditions make
make sure things work out then you can
find integral points just by looking for
terms of the sequence which are one
because that's a denominator of your
rational point then it's actually an
integer point yep sequence has fetishes
but Fibonacci numbers go backward isn't
the curve yeah that's a good question
actually from this previous definition
here I didn't mention but we're
including the degenerate cases on both
sides of this so on the right hand side
I'm quote-unquote degenerate cases are
the integers and the Fibonacci numbers
are the Lucas numbers on the other side
those correspond to singular curves so
if you get a cusp you'll get the
integers and if you get a node you'll
get the Fibonacci numbers on this side
just kind of interesting or not just
Fibonacci numbers but some Lucas numbers
something like that
okay so some of the research that's been
done in terms of about elliptic
divisibility sequences I'll just mention
maybe that the first few of these so
there are applications to elliptic curve
discrete log problem Rachel ship see and
her thesis gave a way of give a
definition of an elliptic divisibility
sequence discrete log problem and so in
certain cases which are known already to
be cryptographically week she was able
to solve the elliptic curve discrete log
problem using the sequences and I'll
actually mention her work a little later
when I'm talking about the tape pairing
in terms of that last property that i
gave Mohammed I odd has published a
paper where he manages to find to give
an algorithm for finding integer points
which which applies only again in
certain cases and applies only to rank
one curves because you you're just
looking at the multiples of one point
and the third one there I guess it
relates to the question we just had
elliptic divisibility sequences are in
some sense for for number theorists
there of interest because in some sense
the the first non linear recurrence or
the most basic nonlinear occurrence that
you might try to study and so a lot of
the research done has had to do with
comes from the number theory side of
things you know the appearance of primes
and those sorts of things okay so a sort
of natural question to ask would be well
this sequence is giving you some
information about the cyclic subgroup of
the more delve a group generated by a
given point so can you can you just do
this for a larger subgroup in the more
delve a group or even the whole thing
now the question is stated the way I
have it written here isn't exactly the
right one because we don't really want
I'll explain I'll explain what I mean by
that in a minute but the general idea is
can you get an integer associated to
each point so that somehow your you're
getting these numbers that don't they're
not a group now that I have some other
sort of properties that's given by the
recurrence relation but reflecting the
group's truck
okay so what do I mean specifically well
suppose you take two points which are
independent and non torsion okay then
the subgroup they generate can be
indexed by side cross said and so then
we can just say well let's try and
associate an integer to each of the
points in that subgroup so each linear
combination MP + NQ now I can do this in
general rank and i'll point out anywhere
where where the results don't work for
all n or for all rank when I say rank i
mean the the rank of the red cross said
there is ranked 2 but on the slides I'll
always be showing things in rank to
because it's just too messy to go
writing things in general okay so then
the definitions we had before but now
for the rank 2 case now you can define a
doubly elliptic function because now we
have to take a curve and two points to
generate a net and then so choosing
those two rational points than just
taking the values you get a net or you
can do it by initial conditions and a
recurrence relation again so here you
need a lot more initial data but this
recurrence relation as I've written it
here is is the recurrence relation for
all in this is the recurrence relation
in general and the recurrence relation
given before by Morgan Ward is actually
just a specific instance of this one so
this applies to the sequences case as
well
now notice that I'm giving it in terms
of vectors and Zed cross said so here's
an example again this extends to
infinity in all directions i'm just
giving the sort of first part of the
first quadrant here so for instance the
laser pointer again for instance the 13
here corresponds to 3p plus 2 q so this
is actually the same curve and point P
that I had in my first example but now
I've chosen another point Q and so if
you go along the x-axis there this is
just the elliptic divisibility sequence
that we saw associated to pee if you go
up this you'll see the elliptic
divisibility sequence associated to the
point Q and in fact any line through the
origin you get an elliptic divisibility
sequence this would be the one
associated to P plus Q you can also take
lines that don't go through the origin
and look at those integer sequences they
satisfy recurrences as well and have
been studied independently they're often
referred to as translated elliptic
divisibility sequences in they were
studied by Christine swart and alpha and
important and they're an instance of so
most sequences so elliptic divisibility
sequences and translated elliptic
visibility sequence or instances of so
most sequences okay so what are the
divisibility when I first was doing this
I was calling them elliptic divisibility
nuts because they do have an appropriate
property but but it was just too
cumbersome to say all the time so what
are the divisibility well in the
one-dimensional case the divisibility
property was really that the primes
appeared at even intervals so let's look
at all the even numbers in here all the
numbers rizal by 2 and they appear in an
even in a nice sub lattice of Zed
crossing so this is the divisibility
concept
okay so um so I show that the
definitions that we have their
equivalent and moreover you can go back
and forth explicitly and you have really
sort of n plus two pieces of data that
determining that the one direction is is
always fairly easy to go from the curve
to the net but to go backwards and
sometimes a big pain so most of the
polynomials which determine the
Weierstrass equation associated to a
given that where I've chosen certain
initial conditions up top okay so I'm
for proofs of things I'm just going to
give a couple of notes and feel free to
ask me more questions but to show for
the one direction you simply have to
show that these will unfold elliptic
functions satisfy the recurrence and
that's a fairly straightforward thing
that then should go backwards what you
can do is you can figure out what curve
and point you should have by looking at
the axes where you know that those are
just elliptic divisibility sequences and
then from the rank one case you can
figure out what curve and point it's
supposed to be and then you have to of
course prove that if you if you do that
then you get and then you come back
again you get the same that you started
with so that the axes actually determine
what the net is so there's a lot of sort
of technical stuff using the recurrence
relation in here and it's actually sort
of an interesting question to try and
explore the space of recurrences this is
quite complicated
all right about the integrality in the
one-dimensional case is fairly simple if
you start with integers and w 2 divides
w 4 then you can prove with a cute
little induction that it's integral but
it gets rapidly more difficult and I you
know there's there's some real reason
why these things take integer values or
else maybe they stop taking in your
values for some large n both of those
would be interesting questions but at
the moment just using complicated messy
inductive proofs by controlling the
division going on and picking the
recurrence relations appropriately I can
prove that they take integer values
given appropriate initial conditions up
to dimension or rank 6 so that's a
frustrating hole in what I can do at the
moment and as I said you just have to
sort of control the visibility okay um
but what's really interesting I think is
reducing mod p so this is probably the
most important important theorem which
is that and I've tried to write it in
some way that that explains what I'm
doing but really what I'm saying is just
what we said before which is that if you
have a curve and some points and you
take the elliptic net associated to that
and you look at it mod p that's really
in some sense appropriately reflecting
the reduced curve mod p and the points
that you produced mod p on that curve
and as an example here now I've
highlighted the terms which are
divisible by five on the same curve so
let's reduce mod p oh sorry really smart
five and that's what we get so this so
something sort of a subtlety but very
important glad I right now which is that
the elliptic net is not a function of
the points in the subgroup of the more
delve a group that I'm talking about
because if it were then let me use the
pointer here if it were then this
parallelogram here should just repeat
because we've shown that C 3 P plus Q is
0 so 3 p+ q+ another P should be the
same as just pee right if it were
actually a function of the points but
it's not it's a function of the formal
linear combinations of the points even
even when the points are torsion or
dependent somehow okay so going going
back to those original slides when I
said it was independent and non torsion
you can actually do it in general it's
just you have to be aware of the fact
it's not really a function but we don't
really want just a function of the group
itself function is I'd cross said okay
so so the zeros indicate where the the
point goes to the point infinity but
these other numbers are a little bit
mysterious they don't seem to repeat
parallelogram to parallelogram and in
fact we'll get into that more detail in
a second okay so the proof of the
reduction theorem what to say about that
you really it's really a question of
looking at the instead of this unfold
product of elliptic curves you want to
look at it as a as a scheme / spec said
and you want to know that if you extend
these elliptic functions then over the
special fibers they'll behave properly
and whatnot in some sense what I'm
saying is if you think of them as
polynomials like the division
polynomials
then the they shouldn't have any
denominators or they should have integer
coefficients without any GCD so in order
to do that you can you can develop
enough of the theory of how these nets
behave under endomorphisms of the unfold
product of the curve and then that
allows you to do a cute trick to reduce
to the rank one case and it does rely on
in reality theorem so that means I can
only do it up to N equals 6 so here's
the statement of the divisibility
property which is a consequence which is
just that if you look for the terms in
your net which are divisible by P those
will appear as a sub lattice okay I'll
let you read this slide for one second
while I drink
so this is for the sequences case so it
doesn't your elliptic divisibility
sequence when you reduce mod p won't
actually have period are it'll have
period some multiple of our and if you
know the first our terms okay we're ours
i forgot to mention our it's called
usually called the rank of apparition
here it's where the it's the order of
the point or the first zero which
appears mod pink okay so if you know the
first our terms of your sequence then
you can determine the next block
according to this periodicity relation
here and then you can determine the
block after that and so on and because
this a and B have some order you'll
eventually get back to having the same
block that you had in the first place so
it will have some your sequence will
have some period which is a multiple of
our okay and there's formula for the a
and B which you can calculate explicitly
now this was shown by Morgan board right
I'm going to restate it in a form which
is generalizable because if you try to
generalize this statement you get a page
full of ugly formulas again so let's say
you take an elliptic divisibility
sequence and you're looking at over a
finite field so that the Arts term
vanishes then there's some alpha which
is not necessarily in that finite field
but whose our power is so that an
appropriate scaling of the elliptic
divisibility sequence will actually have
period exactly are and you can go back
to the other statement of this
periodicity according to the formulas
therefore a and B so this isn't as
intuitive here I really sort of think of
it this way but but this is a statement
which we can generalize for Nets so
supposing now that you have two vectors
giving the vanishing mod p then taking
the GCD of those coordinates
interestingly there's some alpha whose
deeth power is
in that finite field and then you can
appropriately scale the elliptic net in
order to get it periodic exactly with
respect to that lattice and again this
unfortunately is restricted to n less
than or equal to 6 at the moment
although I don't have any reason to
think it's not true in general of course
yeah you only American experiment to see
whether it seems to load for seven or
eight um no I haven't run any je ne
gigantic nuts like that just because I'm
not quite sure how to visualize the data
or a deal with it but and because I
haven't really had any use for it at the
moment but but I should I don't know um
okay so the proof for periodicity oh
yeah the so this conditions here that it
vanishes at those points that tells you
something about those points because
remember then they must be on the they
must be on the zero part of the divisor
so so knowing that you can then just
sort of plug that into the elliptic
functions and this is what you do a lot
of the time now that we have this
reduction theorem is you can prove
something in the case of curves over the
complex numbers using the elliptic
function theory and then just reduce mod
p and it'll still hold over finite
fields and there's a lot more of these
sort of periodicity results christine
swart and her thesis gives well her
thesis is just tons and tons of these
results for elliptic divisibility
sequences and also for translated
elliptic divisibility sequences and so
you can do this in general everything
generalizes and and you get all kinds of
information so for instance you can look
at what's the periodicity mod powers of
a prime and how does that relate to the
periodicity mod the prime and stuff like
that okay ah so now on to the the
cryptography so
um it's okay so that's that's the sort
of basic information about the elliptic
Nets I just wanted to tell you it's
going back for a second to keep this
slide in mind all right we'll come back
to why this has to do with tape pairing
okay the tape pairing so this is just a
pairing on points on elliptic curve you
actually have to choose a positive
integer and take call it m and then
restrict one of the points has to be an
M torsion point and we consider the
other point as as living emod m.e so um
given that your point P is an M torsion
point you will always have this divisor
being principal so you can take the
Associated function f p and for the
point Q you can take a divisor which is
linearly equivalent to D minus zero but
with disjoint support from the divisor
of FP and then you can just use this
formula and you get a pairing it's
bilinear pairing it's non degenerate it
is not symmetric which took me a while
to figure out because Joe told me it was
symmetric when he first told me what it
was so pairings the tape pairing in the
Bay pairing in particular are of
interest to cryptography because the
number of protocols based on on on
having this extra thing you can do with
your your curve so tank pairing actually
comes from the elliptic nets it turns
out so this is basically the same setup
we had before over here except i'm
taking the point s just it's some other
point which is not zero or minus q and
then take some elliptic net such that at
the vectors s P and Q its associated the
points s P and Q then the tape pairing
can be calculated using this formula
right here
so just a note that in order to prove
this what you really do is you say that
the net you choose doesn't matter so you
show that there's a notion of
equivalence of nets which that formula
is invariant under and then that means
that you can choose an appropriate net
so the quotient functions is exactly
what you want and you can just prove it
directly at that point all right and
because we have this freedom of choosing
an appropriate net we can pick we can
pick some appropriate nets to make the
calculations fairly simple so in
particular if you want to pair a point
with itself you might as well just
choose the one-dimensional case because
it's easy to deal with and then this
formula will look like this and that's
what I want you to notice because this
is exactly the formula for a in the
periodicity slide which i'm not sure
will back all the way back up there but
and in the two-dimensional case you can
of course choose two points and take the
net generated by those two points P and
Q and some appropriate quotient there
will give you the tape pairing so um I
actually wanted to point out one thing
which I didn't make a slide 4 so I'm
just going to write something up on the
board here which is that yeah
alright um what is so your period st
relation looks something like this
ok
so
alright so if we wanted to isolate a we
can just do this this is sort of where
the firm that comes from in the
one-dimensional case do this with n and
then do it with n plus 1 and I probably
got this upside down we're going to get
a to the N be over a to the n plus 1 be
okay so I got the inverse of a I did
this last time I was doing this too okay
so what I wanted to point out is that
this gives you a way of seeing if these
points suppose you have the data w n NW
n plus 1 so you have those terms and
suppose you also have the terms w n plus
R + WN + 1 + R so you have two little
chunks of your divisibility sequence
remember I'm just doing this for the
sequence case at the moment here you're
too little chunks of your divisibility
sequence then you can tell if their
distance are apart by actually wait a
second let me assume I have three pieces
here sorry
and plus one foot to sorry plus R okay
so suppose I have the three chunks there
you can tell if they're a distance R
apart by simply taking these the first
two and checking that what you get is
the same as when you take the second
pairs and see if you get the same thing
because if you're a distance R apart
then you get this nice divisibility
relation if you're not a distance R part
you just gonna get some other nonsense
so this is sort of the sense in which
the the curves can be used as an
alternate way of computing things so for
instance if you wanted to know if you
have a point which is period are then
you could use this method of doing it
the same way that you would normally
yeah Barry normally everything gets on a
finite field so I was also disability
apply well what I mean is if you if
you're looking at curves over Q for
instance and you reduce mod p then
you're working over the finite field FP
and i can actually do all these things I
should have said earlier for any number
field so you can reduce mod any prime in
a number field okay then you can work
over the finite field that you get but I
keep for the slides I keep putting Q and
P because it's a little clearer to look
at okay so what I was saying here is
just so the simple question of checking
whether finding the order of your point
for instance I mean short of multiplying
and checking as you go up when it hits
zero right you might try to do some
silly algorithm where you jump around
and see if you get some collisions to
check something like you would for if
you're trying to solve the elliptic
curve discrete log problem you do the
same thing with the nets okay so it's
just a sort of alternate computation
computational model okay I don't that
was
part missing from my talk there so okay
so to actually calculate the tape
pairing going back to the tape pairing
now if you have these formulas like this
what you need to do to calculate it is
somehow or other you have to start with
the initial conditions because your
curve and points tell you the initial
conditions for the net if you start with
that data and you need to somehow
calculate out to the point em to a
distance m from the origin so you can do
this using a double and add formula so
this is based on an algorithm by Rachel
ship see this is what she was doing in
her thesis she gave a double and add
algorithm using blocks of the sequence
to calculate out in to a distance m in
log m time so using the second formula
sorry for flipping the slides back and
forth a couple of times but using the
second formula at the bottom here you
can see there's sort of two types of
terms there's the ones that include a
queue and the ones that don't okay so in
the block that I'm taking these are from
the sequence that don't include the
queue it's kind of like the x-axis and
the picture I had before and these are
from the second row up here that include
1q so then taking this this whole block
it gives enough information to calculate
a whole block centered at 2k remember
the recurrence relation is actually a
fairly complicated has lots of terms in
it so you can't just go term to term
you're going to need to take a whole
bunch of whole block of terms in order
to be able to calculate the next one and
this is sort of the best I could come up
with but of course um you know perhaps
it's possible to do a computer search of
the recurrent space to come up with
something much more efficient but the
idea is to choose some appropriate block
and then you can jump to a block at 2k
or 2k plus 1 and then you can use a
Dublin add algorithm to to get out to
distance mmm is a Miller's algorithm for
the date wedding is a kind of
um in the k equals 1 case I answer that
question in a second how's that Miller's
algorithm is also a double and add
algorithm like this okay except he's
sort of doing calculations which have to
do with the you know doubling the point
on the curve as you go but it also
breaks down into double and double add
okay so then just to sum up the the way
you would calculate it is you take the
net and the points sorry that curve and
the points calculate the associated net
and then use the Dublin add algorithm to
get out to the distance you need and
just plug that into the formula ok so
I'll answer your question with respect
to this slide usually in cryptographic
applications what you're really doing is
you're working with a curve which is
defined over fq but then you take the
smallest k such that M divides Q to the
K minus 1 and then your tape pairing
that this is sort of to make your tape
pairing sufficiently interesting your
tape pairing then the group that it
takes values and will be as big as it
can be and and for cryptographic
applications usually choose the point P
to live in the smaller field and Q to
live up in the larger one and this is
because if you let P live in the smaller
one computationally in Miller's
algorithm that saves you a lot of work
because working the smaller field is
easy and in fact you can sort of ignore
all the work you do in the smaller field
that turns out but you need for security
you need to actually be working in FQ to
the case so you take you up there and
for embedding degree one in Miller's
algorithm then you then you have to
choose an extra point and I guess you
can do that randomly in in higher
embedding degree I think there's a way
of avoiding doing that because of this
okay
think of me as algorithm is also being a
dumb mistake oh yeah I guess yeah I do
well yeah it is it is but you have a lot
of choices and you could choose from all
these different nets and some you know
maybe there's some reason to do that but
I don't think so okay and a note about
the embedding degree is that for
security you want your curve to have
something like 2 to the 160 elements or
something like that but you don't be
able to reduce to the discrete log
problem on a finite field which is too
small because then that wouldn't be safe
so the embedding degree the embedding
degree has to be relatively large so
that so that you don't have to get a
curve which is really really big just in
order to guarantee the security so
usually for cryptographic applications
the embedding degree is somewhere
between like six and ten or something
would be ideal ok so for in terms of
looking at the efficiency I just did
noted squaring and multiplications in
the lower field as s and M and SK and
mk4 ones that you have to do in larger
larger field and both millers in the net
algorithm are double or double an ad
algorithm so I've just broken it down by
the steps double and double add and
these are the numbers okay where did I
get these numbers well millers um these
are the numbers suggested by Michael
Scott as an efficient implementation
there are so many optimizations and
implementations with different you know
different conditions in which they work
and whatnot so I just tried to pick
something representative of what was
fairly good and the net algorithm there
that's just basically the way I've
presented it here with some really
simple optimizations I could do so much
more complicated optimizations but they
weren't even worth trying to explain for
the amount of optimization that you get
out of them so this is this is just the
basic
the basic complexity and then I've just
for particular embedding degrees ranging
from 2 to 12 there I've given examples
of how many steps it would take this has
actually been implemented in I wrote
down the names because I can so this is
this algorithm for the tape pairings
been implemented by Ben Lynn who's a
student of dan Binet in the public the
pairing based cryptography library so he
just wrote to me to tell me he done that
recently and he tested it for embedding
degree 2 and said it was indeed about
twice as slow and he suggests that maybe
some windowing could optimize it or
things like that so I haven't I haven't
tried you know looking into those
optimizations yet also Michael Scott and
his student Augusto dundavie Glee I'm
not sure I said that correctly they also
implemented it and sent me the the code
and whatnot they implemented another
optimization based on an idea of
twisting the curve so that your point Q
doesn't have to be in quite such a large
field and he said I quote it's only a
little slower so I'm not exactly sure
what that means then Lin also mentioned
that he thinks for embedding degree K
equals 1 were a lot of these
optimizations for millas algorithm don't
really apply and you have to sort of do
more work that may be there it would be
more more efficient so so I I don't know
um I I hope that you know if it's really
you know given a chance to try and
optimize this and stuff I hope that the
efficiency could improve quite a bit but
that's where it stands
okay so that's it for the cryptography
and I'm just going to mention a couple
possible other directions to head with
research one is is it possible to do
this for jacobians of higher genus
curves this is something that I've been
keeping in the back of my mind for for
ages as I've been working on this and
there's some really intriguing
connections and stuff people have tried
to do this with elliptic divisibility
sequences in different ways and if it
could I gather for genus two in
particular we would probably have
cryptographic applications because the
computations there are much more
complicated than on elliptic curve also
can you use the periodicity relations to
find integer points just as Muhammad I
ad does but this time you could do it
for curves of higher rank because you've
got the Nets instead of just the
sequences also other computational
applications this it contains the
information what the order of the point
is reduced mod p so it contains the
information in some sense of the size of
your curve over over finite fields and
so maybe there's some way of like using
that information you know it's there in
the periodicity relation and maybe you
can somehow harness that but that's a
very open vague question and of course
are there other cryptographic
applications of the tape pairing
relationship or just of using them
computationally so I'll just leave you
with some references Morgan Ward's
original paper is called a memoir on
elliptic divisibility sequences
Christine Swartz thesis which I
mentioned it's called lip the curves and
related sequences I've got tons of
information in there and if you want an
overview of the literature associated to
elliptic divisibility sequences there's
a whole chapter and recurrent sequences
by everest and report inch parlance kyun
ward and that's a that covers all the
different aspects of what you might
study with with that and there are now
three implementations of the algorithm
available one is in the pairing based
cryptography library there another is a
little Perry script I wrote on my
webpage originally and and also I'm sure
Michael Scott would be willing to
share the implementation that that he
did so there you go i go to the wedding
yes the vape pen can be computed as to
take pairings so you could just do that
I suppose well let's see you would have
to because it's P Q and Q P you would
have to go out the net in one direction
and another direction I'm not sure if
there's some way maybe if you chose if
you cleverly chose your net you'd be
able to walk in the same direction to
get both pieces of information that's a
good idea I haven't thought about
whether that's possible yeah whose ID
systems and always always go to a heart
to heart to a higher form a feeler power
of P I thought this table at VMA maybe
with a twist of it yeah I don't know
very much about using twists in that
case but it allows you to not work in
the full embedding degree but some are a
little bit lower but I probably was a
photographer in the room who would be
able to answer that better than I did a
few minutes for like characteristic two
and three or the super singing the ones
with the embedding degrees like six and
so they usually have there's a couple of
only a few choices for different person
that integrates there but you could can
do it more generally greatly work out of
ordinary curves but that's a statesman
in the same curve let a little extent
and ab de lourdes then maybe better
growth yeah i was going to ask about the
generalizations of genus 2 so kind of
what would you hope for there would you
you'd hope to find points on the
Jacobian that would whose multiples like
that would correspond to the values of
yeah well I guess um yeah it's hard it's
hard to know which direction that
generalization would go one way of
looking at this periodicity relation is
that well I guess I don't really need to
write starting to say but one way of
looking at the periodicity relation is
that the extra information you have
because it's not really a function just
to the points so you sort of more
information in the group what's actually
going on there is it's it's a it's
giving the it's giving a extra
information that you would get if you
took an extension of the curve by the
multiplicative group so if you took a
generalized Jacobian instead of just the
elliptic curve so it's possible that for
genus 2 jacobians again you would just
get something which has this sort of
periodicity relation like this that's
that's sort of reflecting the
generalized Jacobian for that Jacobian
but I don't I don't know if it would
necessarily satisfy a recurrence
relations still another way of
generalizing it would be to see whether
there's some recurrence that would work
for that case and maybe maybe those
wouldn't even coincide so maybe it
wouldn't have the same behavior in that
case it's very hard to say
you